alors la communauté internationale
peut-elle arriver à coordonner ses
efforts pour anéantir le groupe etat
islamique
je joins marie-eve bédard qui est à
beyrouth christian latreille qui est à
washington devant l'ambassade de france
qui commence avec vous christian en
revue le président obama reste convaincu
que les frappes aériennes sont la bonne
stratégie
il est très fidèle céline à sa stratégie
qu'il a mis en place il ya maintenant
plus d'un an c'est à dire celle de ses
frappes aériennes très ciblée sur le
groupe etat islamique armée en irak et
en syrie
pas question selon le président
américain il l'a répété la marteler
encore une fois aujourd'hui
pas question de troupes au sol et vous
savez les américains ne suivent la pluie
dans cette démarche via un sondage qui a
été publié aujourd'hui et qui mentionne
que les états unis bon les américains en
veulent davantage veulent que ces
frappes s'intensifient
mais pas question dans une proportion
écoutez bien de 76% d'envoyer des
militaires sur le terrain des états unis
on le sent qu'ils sont encore les
américains encore traumatisé par
l'invasion de l'irak et de l'afghanistan
ils ont un président qui a promis aux
américains en 2008 de les sortir de deux
conflits de deux guerres donc s'engager
dans un troisième serait contraire à ses
principes et à son engagement politique
et barack obama l'a dit aujourd'hui
céline il n'est pas question que les
américains envahissent chaque pays qui
seraient responsables d'attentats
terroristes
ouais de votre côté marie-eve en syrie
si la con frappé la population l'a
durement ressentiez en fin de semaine a
compris un peu ce que ça pouvait dire
l'intensification ces freins ou à la
population syrienne a l'habitude céline
des bombardements mais dès dimanche
havas cas là où la france a bombardé à
larguer une vingtaine de bombes sur deux
cibles du groupe hermitage islamique
les activistes sur place ont laissé
savoir que la population civile était
inquiète face à l'intensité de ces
bombardements
et ce n'est pas comme s'il n'en avait
pas vu dans la vire de palmyre
aujourd'hui un activiste
diriger mais aussi anti groupe hermitage
islamique qui a envoyé sur twitter un
message directement au gouvernement de
la france en leur rappelant fait
attention en bombardant comme ça va
appeler vous qu'il reste toujours une
population civile en syrie et qu'elle
est coincée entre deux feux ce qu'on
voit derrière vous marrez elle ce sont
c'est un orage en fait sont des éclairs
bon le liban lui qui se remet à peine
des attentats meurtriers de la semaine
dernière le pays exprime au fond sa
compassion pour paris mais il ya quand
même une certaine déception la façon
dont on les traite re voilà les libanais
qui sont très attachés à la france
plusieurs ont la double nationalité
passe énormément de temps à paris donc
ont ressenti la douleur des parisiens
mais en même temps se sentent aussi
laissé pour compte par la communauté
internationale ils ont connu les
attentats les plus meurtriers qui
avaient connu le pays jeudi dernier la
veille seulement des attentats de paris
depuis 1990 est il si on se demande où
on était tous ces gestes de soleil
solidarité de la communauté
internationale
on n'a pas vu les grands édifices les
monuments partout sur la planète ce
illuminée aux couleurs du drapeau
libanais alors on recense deux poids
deux mesures et on se demande si leur
vie à eux n'a pas moins de valeur que
l'avis des français mais ne s'est pas
désuni
victime du terrorisme
cette région du monde christian aux
etats unis aujourd'hui on a senti
beaucoup de nervosité sur un autre sujet
sur la question des réfugiés
le président obama céline on le sait
s'est engagé à acquérir au cours des
prochains mois dix mille réfugiés
syriens aux états unis vous savez
aujourd'hui on a entendu tout et son
contraire on sent que particulièrement
depuis qu'on a retrouvé un passeport
syrien tout près du corps d'un des
kamikazes qui s'est fait sauter près du
stade de france vendredi soir dernier
il ya un repli sur soi ici est très fort
aux états unis la peur de l'autre et
exploiter particulièrement par les
républicains qui blâme aussi les
démocrates d'être trop mou aujourd'hui
pour vous dire 22 états dont 21 dirigé
par des gouverneurs républicains ont
carrément refusé d'accueillir ces
réfugiés seulement ils n'ont pas tous
les pouvoirs
c'est une juridiction fédérale
l'émigration aux états unis alors ils
peuvent rendre leur vie plus difficile
mais le président obama a mentionné que
ce serait contraire et ce serait trahir
les valeurs américaines que de leur
fermer la porte et le secrétaire d'état
en france elles soient keita d'état
américain john kerry qui était à
l'ambassade américaine à paris l'a
répété lui également un peu plus tard
nous vaincrons dash et tous ceux qui
partagent son idéologie méprisable et
nous continuerons à montrer de
compassion envers ceux qui cherchent un
refuge
fuyant la violence engendrée par les
terroristes
ben voilà c'est là dessus qu'on va se
laisser merci beaucoup à vous 2 de cet
éclairage de chacun de vos postes
respectifs merci